welcome to another gadget lab show
I'm Michael colori now I'm Nathan only
vadas Giles coming up later we're gonna
have Christina and John showing off some
lightsabers and Robbie's gonna bring in
a Raspberry Pi computer but first Nathan
I couldn't help but noticing that
strange and unusual tablet you're
holding in your hands why yes this is
the Samsung Galaxy Tab 2 10.1 say that
again the Samsung Galaxy Tab 2 10.1 that
is a long yeah
Samsung loves long names I think maybe a
little longer than I like but a samsung
Vincent yeah
so what is it it's just it's a new
Android tablet right yeah a new Android
tablet runs Ice Cream Sandwich the
latest version of Android operating
system and it's very very similar to the
Galaxy Tab 10.1 from last year it looks
almost exactly the same one thing that I
really like though is Samsung is thrown
on some speakers on the front here which
is really similar to a change that they
made to the last version the Galaxy Tab
in Germany to avoid some Apple pen
lawsuit stuff
yeah and that's actually that's I think
one of the better features you can have
in a topic is yeah you're using a tablet
for watching videos watching movie and
the speakers are actually facing towards
you yeah instead of off to the sides or
yeah it's a good move I was watching
some video on it last night you know
working on a review of this device and I
really liked the fun facing speakers it
sounded great yeah there but there are
there are some things of course that I
don't like as well here there's one
change or addition that Samsung has made
here they have a little tray for what
they call mini apps at the bottom and
these mini apps they are mini they are
small but they just pop right over the
top of whatever it is you're doing
and then they just kind of sit there and
it's not the most intuitive thing
I thought at first they might be you
know like widgets like a place around
but no they're not so I guess the idea
is hey if you want to get an app really
fast you can pop in pop out maybe
something to use a lot but I would
rather just go in apps and open up an
actual line otherwise you just have this
like persistent thing floating over the
user experience yeah kind of wonky yeah
it's a little weird it doesn't feel like
it's fully realized or finished you know
and also this is the this is all
a dual-core processor inside of this
thing right yeah Samsung is kept the
hardware here very similar to what
they're offering last year that's
probably why it's only 400 bucks instead
of you know more but yeah it's a
dual-core processor it's not quad core
like we're gonna see from Asus and Acer
and you know Toshiba's coming out with
some quad core tablets too so they're
not trying to chase that you know arms
race on that side they're keeping it
pretty similar they had last year
interesting and do you notice a big
performance hit you know I do feel like
in navigating through the operating
system and in launching apps that
there's a little bit sluggishness here
compared to some of the quad core
tablets that I've tested out but I don't
even know if it's right to blame that on
to fewer cores in this device because
the iPad 2 and 3 those things scream and
I don't notice the same sort of
sluggishness over there and those are
dual core devices right yeah so it's a
software issue yeah I think it really
comes down to how these different
companies take the software they build
it and integrate it with the hardware
it's really a full package and you can't
just add on or take away some extra
hardware and expect it to be better yeah
so I guess it's sort of a combination of
the system-on-a-chip
architecture and getting to getting the
hardware companies sort of getting used
to writing software for that yeah and
the operating system believes on top of
it yep yep well you know that's the
thing that I've noticed about Android
devices as of late is that you know
everybody is so concerned about the
specs you know any courses that have
yeah how much RAM is in it yeah you know
and that's and that's like what's really
driving the the decision-making around
purchases of these things but it's it's
really it's mostly about what it's like
to pick it up and use it however that is
implemented doesn't really matter yeah
it's just that's the most important
thing that you should look for when
you're buying something not what's
written on the paper yeah your if you if
you you know buy one of these devices
you're gonna have to live with it every
day and just what's written on a spec
sheet doesn't necessarily mean that it's
better or worse he actually got to go
out use it try it out you know read our
reviews I don't care if the scrolling
isn't smooth I want four chords exactly
exactly
well anyway thank you for bringing that
in and you'll be able to read Nathan's
full review on wired calm in the reviews
section soon yeah give a first look of
this
no no no we're not gonna do one all
right so you're gonna have to wait to
see all of our gorgeous product
photography that we're gonna be posting
around this tablet but you will not have
to wait to learn everything you've never
wanted to know about lightsabers oh yeah
hey Kristina today it looks like a
lightsaber
that's no lightsaber at all this is a
lightsaber this is the laser saber from
wicked lasers it's $100 polycarbonate
attachment for further actual lasers
that they already sell the Spider 3
Series that's right it doesn't work of
any old laser nor any old wicked lasers
laser it has to be a spider 3 series the
the Arctic which is blue or the Krypton
which is green and basically this this
comes off that's the laser saber it
attaches to your existing Spider 3 and
it's got that cool magnetic anti-gravity
system where this should sort of go down
but the problem with the system is that
you know you want a sheath and unsheath
your laser with a sure well it does it
but to sort of sheet the back up I found
you sort of have to hit it like that but
you could unsheath it just like that
well it does have different modes this
is the low power mode on the laser
itself and so I'm gonna hopefully kick
it into high power mode let let's see
what it looks like oh my god so huge
laser action right there you can't see
anything with the orange safety glasses
on I'm gonna take my chances without the
safety glasses if this was not in the
Laser saber casing you would have to
wear the glasses and in fact they
recommend to not even use this device
without the safety glasses but I'm not
looking at the terminus of the of the
lightsaber which would really mess up
your eyes so this is the Laser saber
let's see if we
again no see it doesn't wanna unsheath
that's right here we go one more time
killer and also it looks great with the
lights off too so in daylight like which
we're approximating in the studio right
now it's it's spectacular if this was
nighttime or if we turned the lights off
it would be even more bright
so Robbie on a scale of one to ten how
big 7.89 that's very precise I try to be
very precise you should be programmer I
should be a programmer if you were would
you buy a Raspberry Pi board even you
know I'm not a programmer but I should
be and I actually did buy a Raspberry Pi
board pretty awesome what is that
so the Raspberry Pi board is a it's a
microcomputer it runs three there's
three distros of Linux you can run on it
and you can get one for 25 or 35 dollars
so $25 version comes with one USB port
and no Ethernet the $35 one that extra
ten bucks will get you Ethernet and an
extra USB port so you have to use a hub
for you know whatever and it also has
one like HDMI and have standard HDMI a
standard video out audio out SD slot has
an SD slot and the it doesn't come with
an SD card but you know you download the
distro from raspberry PI's site and you
just throw it on SD card which you can
pick up like anywhere now I think they
sell them at liquor stores and you just
gonna do slide it in there and there you
go that's your that's your that's your
your drive it's pretty hot what do
people use it on force well they made
them because they found that the entry
level for computers became very high and
and also the people who are buying
computers it's a family computer so you
know back in the day the only person had
a computer was usually the super you
know geeky kid in the family
and you know yeah and then you could do
whatever on it because no one else uses
the computer you could you can crash it
you could write code you could do
whatever but now everyone in the house
is using the computer so they created
this so it's a it's a very low entry
price point for a computer and you can
do whatever you can learn how to code
with this and it comes with the Eclipse
development software so which is which
is really nice
you know if you want to learn how to
develop like programs yeah it's one of
the more popular plug-in to your TV you
can plug it into pretty much you know
anything that you know composite out or
HDMI with audio so people could use this
you know for like a recording device
they can use it as like a home theater
PC or something like that
yeah well mostly for streaming because I
mean and you should keep like one movie
on here oh yeah but you could you could
yeah you could put X NBC on it it's you
know you can run quake on it which is
you know it's it's it's not the fastest
thing as 256 Meg's of RAM it has an ARM
processor okay so it's kind of limited
yeah it's it's limited but it's it's one
of those things it's like meant to get
people into the whole idea of
programming and building their own
custom hardware and things like that
yeah yeah it's definitely it's a super
fun super geeky a little saying it's you
know like I said I just want this the
$35 version it's it's it's just cool I
mean 35 bucks for a computer well yeah
that's actually that's actually a
problem because from what I've heard
these things are ridiculously difficult
to get your hands on yeah yeah so what
sort of skullduggery did you I had to
why I was I had it because we're we're
covering it on wired so so you threw
down the Big W so yeah so I kind of said
I kind of throw down the Big W in order
to secure this bag but I paid for it
because I want one and I'm a firm
believer if there's something I want and
I will pay for it lottie's Ellis people
out there you go yeah yeah I'm sorry I'm
sorry but they're making more and it's
yeah it is definitely it's the price
point is so low and it is so intriguing
and kind of you know an awesome that
it's it's it it's they're having
difficulty keeping up with demand well
good I guess it's a you know a good
problem to have for them yeah and hoping
it they hope they get so Richard ruins
them yeah my grandfather always used to
say well thanks for showing off the
Raspberry Pi as I'm sure you're gonna
build something awesome and intriguing
with it
you're gonna post about I should also
gadget lab yeah yeah I have a couple
ideas for this thing I mean you can put
it into like a little RC cars a little
robot computer you can do everything ya
build like custom like this is for it
you can create back to the drawing board
how'd you come up with something better
all right robot mind-blowing robots be
cool well we can't wait to see what
Rodney builds with it
and I'm sure you can't wait to show it
off oh yeah definitely
I'm a big show-off that's all we have
time for this week and we'll be back
next week on the Gadget Lab we'll see
then